Hey guys My name is J McDonald It is the
18th of November Today and you're
watching games SP News Australian
Edition well Global News Australian
host Assassin's Creed Unity has been
accused of Being propaganda by a former
French politician Yep that's a Thing
That actually happened  former French
minister and presidential candidate Jean
M Isn't too Happy with the Way The Game
deps The French revolution he Said game
deps historical figures like Mar
Antoinette and King Louis x in a
Positive Light While showing The French
masses as savages M Is currently The
Leader of the left party a French
democratic socialist political party
ubisoft are yet to comment On The Bold
claims Dragon AG Inquisition Isn't
having much Luck either having been
removed from sale in India due to the
country's absen laws the games publisher
EA decided To Make  The Game No longer
available preorder in the region for
what a spokes person has Said is due to
Local absen laws but not specific to
Same Gender Romance the game esrb
content description can give you a
Pretty Good Idea of ​​Why EA May have
decided to pull the  game from the region
given The Fairly colorful language that
Goes along with the game sex scenes not
Safe for News unfortunately but you can
Check out some examples on gamespot If
You're Curious For People Who Have
already preorder in the
refund will be available Sony have  Said
They are too worried about the recent
Xbox One Price Cut taking business away
from Them in the coming Months SCA
president Seanladen told gamet that he
expects The Holiday season to be
competitive but they don't feel Any
pressure as a result of the 50  Xbox One
up against Their 00 PS4 that Might be
because Sony are also offering a Black
Friday Bundle Which includes a PS
console GTA 5 And The Last Of Us
Remastered for 400 Bucks loading also
added that he's Pretty pleased With The
Sales numbers When asked If It  Would Be
accurate to suggest that the PS4 has a
two to One Advantage over the xBox One
in turns of unit Sold loading replied
diplomatic The Math seems to look like
that as your question of the day let me
know if you think some games are to Oben
or If You're Okay with it you can head
to gamot for More stories on things like
the chief collections matchmaking fix
Being delayed and GTA 5 character
transfer issues that is it for me Today
I'll Be Back Time Tomorrow so I do Hope
see
you